Red Rock Canyon is suffering from  extreme drought as we all know and  that's why save at Red Rock is  partnering with a group of scientists on  a groundbreaking new cloud seating  program with potential to bring much  needed rain and snow melt to our thirsty  Canyon now cloud seeding is what it's  called and it introduces tiny ice nuclei  into subfreezing clouds well after this  the newly formed snowflakes grow and  they fall to the ground in turn  generating more water  eventually we want the government to  take over but to for that to happen they  need to see public support and they need  to have local public matching and to  show the government that this is worth  it the public is behind you  well the goal is to raise a hundred and  fifty thousand dollars to take it to the  state legislature for more information  on getting involved you can go to our  website 8newsnow.com